hey everybody is Charlie we got a whole
bunch of new Shazam footage to break
down as you can tell referencing a lot
of Big Man of Steel and Batman V
Superman moments they'll reference stuff
from all the different Justice League
character films maybe Aquaman is an
exception just because they were making
this while they were making the Aquaman
movie but remember this takes place in a
world after the events of Justice League
so all the Shazam children Billy Batson
Freddy Freeman
Mary Marvel all those kids know about
the Justice League we're still doing the
IMAX giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a Sam
comment on the video so this is mostly
Shazam vs. dr. sivana in foreshadowing
the seven deadly sins you get like a
couple really big shots of the seven
deadly sins so even though most of the
marketing is trying to keep this pretty
simple and give you an idea for the tone
of the film like they even went so far
is to put the text in this actual
trailer not so serious and then he makes
the joke about trying to buy the beer
your finest beer please as the teller
just could give a crap about what he's
doing like you probably thinks is some
sort of cosplayer like yeah whatever
this is all probably happening during
that big robbery scene where he's like
oh my god I'm bulletproof you're dead
and then you see him trying to buy all
the junk food later
[Music]
because Aquaman was such a huge hit most
of their marketing is focusing on the
tone and sort of hitting the beats of
the previous Justice League films like
Man of Steel where they're punching each
other while flying through the air
there's already been a crazy number of
jokes and the other trailers about
Batman and Superman and references so
this is just the beginning but he also
displays a couple of his other big
powers during this footage and remember
you know because we're referencing a lot
of Justice League films they'll be
talking about the different Justice
League characters when he's using those
different abilities because some of them
are very similar like his SuperSpeed
when he's rushing to catch the bus and
then switches to different powers with
his super-strength and his ability to
fly when he's trying to catch it from
falling from the overpass
so he looks a little bit like the flash
but he also looks a little bit like
Superman because he can fly super strong
he's invulnerable to stuff like bullets
you get a little bit of footage of him
running off the rooftop like he's
already figured it out and this is
happening later in the film like there's
this very clear horizon shot like it's
meant to be this big hero moment for him
where he's like I know how to do this
now and he runs
and yells the word he get a much better
look in slow motion
of the transition when he's activating
his powers saying his power word so this
is probably after that big montage where
they're like what are your powers well
let's figure it out so they do the funny
montage of them just trying to get him
to do a bunch of different things to see
what he's capable of so if you're not a
big comic book fan Shazam is actually an
acronym for the different powers that he
has it's s for wisdom of Solomon H for
strength of Hercules a for stamina of
Atlas Z for power of Zeus another a for
a courage of Achilles and then M speed
of mercury wisdom of Solomon is exactly
what it sounds like it makes him super
smart for a brief period of time
strength of Hercules is exactly what you
think it is it just makes him super
strong for a little while the stamina of
Atlas gives him his invulnerability so
he can take punches he's bulletproof the
power of Zeus is where all the Lightning
based powers come from and his
immortality so another thing to to
remember is that he'll only age when
he's billy batson when he activates his
powers as long as he doesn't say the
word again to deactivate them he'll live
forever that's how you explain Black
Adam living for 5000 plus years because
way back in ancient Kondik when he got
his powers he never turned them off so
if you ever saw the animated Shazam
movie that's how he winds up defeating
him as he gets him to save the word
again like fight me like a man don't use
your powers but he tricks him when he
changes back his body ages 5000 years
within the span of a couple seconds and
he instantly turns to dust
[Music]
the courage of Achilles is exactly what
it sounds like it just makes him super
confident in himself in the speed of
mercury also exactly what you think it
is it gives him his super speed that
looks a little bit like the flash like
even though you see the yellow streak
right behind him yeah it looks a little
bit like the flash it's gonna be a bit
of a visual reference but the way he
moves is a little bit more like the way
Superman has SuperSpeed because he
doesn't give off lightning the same way
that the flash does I mean he does give
off lightning but when he chooses to
give off lightning it's not like an
automatic thing like the Speed Force the
reason for the yellow streak behind him
when he moves super fast is because of
the yellow lightning bolt you're just
seeing that blur across frame so when
you see dr. sivana and Shazam having
their full-blown wizard battle with the
lightning it looks like something right
out of Star Wars with a Jedi versus the
Emperor even though you don't see a lot
of Jedi using Force Lightning mostly
just the Emperor trying to use it on
other people and people like Master Yoda
either trying to deflect it or absorb it
like when he's with Count Dooku I don't
know because this is Warner Brothers I
don't know how much they're allowed to
reference or poke fun at the Star Wars
movies in this because that feels like
if they're gonna be making a lot of
pop-culture references and you're using
a lot of lightning powers like that then
you would make some sort of Star Wars
reference at some point there is the
funny joke about the lair obviously his
lair should technically be the rock of
eternity the whole reason why the wizard
is choosing him as his next champion is
because he's slowly dying his powers are
fading and he needs someone to pick up
the mantle to protect the world from the
seven deadly sins and keep them
imprisoned inside the rock of eternity
here so obviously a big part of the film
is probably gonna be them being released
or at least teasing that at some point
because dr. sivana story the seven
deadly sins and black Adam are all tied
together even though technically this
isn't meant to be a movie for the Black
Adam character maybe a cameo from the
rock at the end of the film or at least
some moment that lets you know that
black Adam is coming at some point
because I think they're still planning
on making his solo film or if they don't
wind up making that then they'll
definitely put him in the Shazam sequel
whatever that winds up being if you
haven't read it this is mostly based on
the Jeff Jones new 52 Shazam run it
actually started in a Justice League
comic where they sort of set up the
basis for where dr. sivana comes from
why he's searching for the pow
if Shazam white feels like he needs it
so badly and why it is that he becomes a
villain and sort of how his different
powers work because as you can see in
this he seems like he also has the
powers of Shazam
but it's a little bit different what it
sounds like they did though is that they
removed a lot of the Black Adam from
this dr. Savannah's origin story because
the whole idea of his new 52 arc is that
he's searching for power to save his
family and he couldn't find one in
science so he's searching for magical
means which is why he's seeking the
power of Shazam
Wally's tracking down artifacts Indiana
jones-style he comes upon the tomb of
Black Adam and he sees all these symbols
he starts to read from them and get
zapped with some magical lightning in
his eye which as a side effect gives him
the ability to see magical spells in a
way that normal humans can't like so
when he's looking around he could
actually see magical spells in the air
like if he walked past a Zatanna he
could actually see it visualized in a
way that normal people couldn't after he
awakens Black Adam from his eons of
slumber it turns into more of a black
Adam
versus Shazam story in dr. sivana just
sort of a backup character so early
prediction what they've done from the
comics is just separate out those black
Adam and dr. sivana
story arcs from the new 52 run into two
different movies and they'll just deal
with the Black Adam stuff when they get
to the sequel the way they've talked
about Mark Strong sivanna during the
movie is that he's like another
candidate or former candidate for the
powers of Shazam but it turns into this
really twisted father-son familial
relationship story where Billy Batson
has trouble fitting into a family he
comes running from foster home to foster
home they kind of dealt with that in the
first big teaser within dr. savannas
backstory he had a really terrible
relationship with his father so he felt
like he did not have a family like he
was always trying to live up to the
expectations of a father and it became
this really twisted evil thing over time
him just seeking more and more power
they kind of tried to do that same thing
during the Deadpool 2 movie where the
family is an f-word storyline where they
were trying to give fire fists a family
and make him feel like he belonged so
they didn't turn into this really
twisted villain in the future that
darkest timeline scenario is kind of
what dr. sivana is living out right now
he's sort of the darkest timeline
version of what Billy Batson could
become although really I would
ultimately say that's Black Adam but
it'll be interesting to see if there
that family twisted upbringing aspect
with dr. sivana what kind of a storyline
they're gonna play up when they do Black
Adam in the inevitable sequel the rumor
is is they only spend about ninety
million dollars making this film so it
doesn't have to do a lot of money to
actually be profitable so I think even
if it doesn't do gangbusters or make
like eight hundred plus million dollars
it'll still wind up getting a sequel of
some sort people keep asking Zachary
Levi are you gonna cross over with the
other Justice League characters and if
they do another Justice League film will
Shazam be a part of that new team and it
sounds like right now unless something
goes terribly terribly wrong that he
will eventually join a version of the
Justice League in the future but that's
so far off that it's still speculation
at this point so you can still kind of
guess about what you want the next
Justice League movie to look like with
Shazam being part of the team for those
of you asking where the Wonder Woman
1984 trailer is they delayed the movie
to summer 2020 so it's not this summer
but next year's summer they'll probably
hold the trailer till Comic Con later
this year well let me know in the
comments what do you guys think about
Shazam so far while you wait for
everything click here to rewatch the
spider-man far from home trailers a
billion more times and click here for
that really big Avengers Tower Easter
egg thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
you